so you're in a relationship yeah how
long has this been a
oh
prison time for some time now not that
long not that long what what about your
lady because I feel like you're the kind
of guy who I wouldn't expect to be in a
relationship yeah so what about your
lady was like yo this girl's I want to
make this you know I want to put a title
on this you know what's so crazy though
bro cause you are the lover boy yeah I
am
but that's why I tried I try not to like
our relationship I like I used to have
our relationship like so broad on the
internet like I remember seeing that it
used to be everywhere I stopped posting
it though right just because simply I
wanted to keep it away from the world
like they're smart
that's what's going on bro right
because like then you end up in a
situation like shout out to my guy in La
Chapa or like he breaks up with this
girl and then he has to explain what
happened because yeah they're on the
internet together so much right and it's
like
don't know why I really know what's
going on what's going on but you got so
many people in your business that you
feel like you just gotta you got to feel
like you owe it to the like you owe it
to him like you know I mean because then
it's like and what's and it's not sacred
anymore oh yeah so like I don't know I
try to keep that away from the world
because you know I mean they started
paying uh painting image of your
relationship like it's perfect and no
relationship is perfect we're not
[ __ ] perfect like we ain't nowhere
close to perfect and we ain't we not
just gonna act like I'm just Prince
Charming or like I'm just so like I try
to keep that [ __ ] away from the world
because what we got going on people
don't know about yeah I mean so
I do like the uh I like the line that
annalize pushing like let me cheat in
peace that was a very like
I'm sure a lot of men in the world
appreciate him saying that publicly and
they're probably looking at their ladies
like see
just in peace no I'm not one of those
men because I'm I'm happily married I
love my wife my wife
yes he said she wouldn't let me cheat in
peace
what
he had this whole video explanation he
was like she knows what she signed up
for she wouldn't let me do my thing on
the side in peace anymore
wait I don't know bro I mean I respected
yeah he's you know shop is doing a lot
of wild [ __ ] semen retention you know
he's drinking all kinds of [ __ ]
lotions and potions and [ __ ] you know
she's young though he's young as [ __ ]
he's like 18 going on 40 though when you
talk to him I'm like bro you got wisdom
how do you know about all these rude
herbs and roots and all kinds of smart
as hell yoga and [ __ ] yeah I [ __ ] with
him no yeah great guy yeah